well this cafe is not your typical
restaurant it's known for its delicious
food an attractive decor perfect
apparently for that instagram photo
we're talking about cafe lola in fact it
was a voted most instagramable cafe uh
yeah so all this month we're sharing
stories of women who inspire and make a
difference in our community sally
jaramillo profiles the creators behind
the flowers
we started with one four years ago and
we now have four what started as a dream
has now become a reality cafe lola is
the true meaning of the saying hard work
pays off honestly we had no idea what to
expect when we first opened the doors
and to see it flourish the way it has
has been the most rewarding thing ever
alexandra lourdes is the co-founder of
refine hospitality and says one of her
biggest dreams was to create a space for
women to come and enjoy as women we love
to give back and we love to support
other women and our biggest
i mean for me for sure i love
kind of motivating and showing that
anyone can do it lynne jerome principal
co-founder of refined hospitality and
partner agrees we're so supportive of
each other we always look out for each
other and so if i was going to do
anything in any city any community i was
going to do it right here at home so
lynn and alex followed their heart and
they led them to lola a space filled
with live good energy and delicious food
from breakfast and lunch to specialty
cocktails and even dessert it's so
rewarding especially as a first
generation latina because my parents
didn't go to college both lourdes and
lynn graduated from unlv one has a phd
in education the other a law degree
their message to other women in the
valley it wasn't always easy and being a
woman and being a minority there's lots
of hoops and hurdles that you jump
through but you know you keep pushing in
eight years so much has changed if you
don't work your future self you don't
realize what you're capable of sally
haramiyo live local now